It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's a Monday!
Wake up!
Thank you for waking up.
And joining us today for our 124th episode, BAU BAU!
How are you doing?
Is that bad?
I see that.
You are awake!
Let me just fluff that on out.
Sleepy.
It's okay!
No!
FUWAMOCO Morning is now, no more 5 more minutes!
BAU BAU!
Well, for those who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us,
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, do you have it memorized yet?
Are you awake?
You have breakfast!
Don't eat the hashtags for breakfast, okay?
They look like cereal, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Hashtag cereal.
Hashtag breakfast cereal idea.
What?!
It's gonna be extra trendy, Moco-chan!
Don't need to aim it, name it, name it anything!
Just you know, on the box.
It's trendy.
At HelloVenica, hashtag trending.
Good twins in class.
BAU BAU!
There's more disappointing stuff for today.
What is it?
The LT thing.
Yeah.
Well... Obvious.
You know.
What?
There's been another...
Pero Sighting.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, where was he seen this time?
Well, let's take a look.
De-den!
BAU BAU!
That's beautiful.
Nasty but beautiful!
A beautiful cloud!
Was it just about to get stormy there?
You know, sometimes it sort of gets like that.
Yeah, before it got stormy, you know, it started with a nice weather, then it just turned into a horrible rain.
Hopefully it got blown away really fast, you know.
Get in the way of your plans.
Yeah.
All your words.
BAU BAU!
Sometimes Pero can do that, huh?
Get in the way of your words!
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
BAU!
Oh, it's some good news!
Ruffians!
While our lovely demon of sound of hololive English -Advent-, Nerissa Ravencroft just released an MV for her original song, In My Feelings!
BAU BAU BAU!
BAU B
It's the beginning of August!
You might have already heard it!
What?
This is the perfect chance to go listen again!
Yeah!
Now we have a beautiful music video!
The video is something else!
It uses, you know, 3D.
3D like real life!
But you know, it just makes a better chance to really focus in on the lyrics.
Yeah!
To have a lot of feelings that Nerissa wrote herself!
Nerissa wrote herself!
You know, maybe it was written towards
I don't know.
Jailbreak?
Kind of a sad song though, Nerissa.
It's so sad though.
You have to take a look and think about it!
Yeah, take a listen too.
And then, think about your feelings.
And then maybe you'll be in your feelings together with Nerissa-chan.
What's the art?
The art of the video is done by the wonderful Yomousaka-sensei!
Please take a look, there's some very cute illustrations of Nerissa.
She has a cute outfit, you know?
Blue white shirt and black skirt.
And you can see her wings so nicely!
Fuzzy Wings.
Let's go take a whistle, okay?
You know, supporting original music.
Advent.
All the music releases, you know.
Releasing original music.
It's very difficult.
It's not a given, okay?
And we put so much of ourselves into it.
It's very personal.
So please go have a listen, okay?
You always do.
BAU BAU, thank you!
Speaking of original music...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Welcome to the anime Isekai Suicide Squad!
And you know, this music video, it's fully animated by Rit Studio!
Yeah!
Just like the anime!
It's amazing!
Look at Calli-senpai!
Yes!
Okay, Moco-chan.
You know they're perfectly positioned here.
Harley Quinn or Calli-senpai.
Who is the waifu?
You couldn't make me say that.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Who's the waifu?
Huh?
Oof!
Hi!
I have oof for singing the morning!
Calli, it's the dog!
That is true, but dog could be a waifu too!
Can dog be a waifu?
I don't see many answers.
Ruffians, you're not gonna help out Moco-chan!
I think YouTube is so many answers!
Cali is the Hialeah!
That's the answer!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
But in this music video, you can see both Harley Quinn and Calliope by dancing together in two different universes.
I think wild things would happen if the worlds accidentally collided.
It's probably best like that!
Ruffians, the video is so amazing!
That even just after a few hours, it's already at over 1 million views!
1 million!
Congratulations, everyone!
That's so so happy for me!
That's amazing!
Go getters!
Go getting the million viewers!
Yeah, we're so happy for her!
Yeah, you know, I'm sure it's so many hololive members' dream to sing an anime song and I can't cheer for Kelly-san, but it is such an amazing song and amazing music video too.
Right?
Yeah, she has a music video where she's moving together almost in the same world all together with everyone.
Yeah, anime girl!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Do listen, do not listen!
Which one is it, Moco-chan?
Do listen!
Make sure you do listen!
Dad or waifu?
Which one, Moco-chan?
Listen, don't listen!
No more oof!
Go listen, okay?
Go listen.
Go get the listen.
BAU BAU!
I'm not waking up, okay Ruffians?
I'm not.
Yeah.
Got it?
No.
You're the one who's waking up.
Good morning!
Waking up?
Waking up.
BAU BAU!
I hope you like music, Ruffians!
Because!
You know we talked about Nerissa, I generally talked about Kai-senpai and Senpai.
Next, we get to talk about our kohai, Lauda!
hololive English -Justice- just released their second cover song!
BAU BAU!
ECHO!
It's a Vocaloid Goonies song!
It's a classic!
Did you listen?
It's just came out fresh!
Iyana did such an amazing job!
You might have to thank someone special.
Iyana didn't just do the singing, she also did the art too!
Too amazing!
She's too talented!
Right!
That means, Ruffians, that means you need to go and give our Koukai's brand new cover song a good listen, okay?
She worked so hard on it!
I'm just so proud of her!
Koukai's down!
BAU BAU!
What do you think, Ruffians?
Should we release a cover song with us doing the illustrations?
What song would that be, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
Kaeru no uta ga kikoete kuru yo.
BAU!
Your frog is a good baller.
Yes.
Bye bye!
You watch it.
I think I could draw a picture of a frog.
I think.
That's a lot of confidence you got there.
BAU BAU!
BAU NEXT, RuffianS!
It's the time!
We're all excited!
The regular quarter!
Do you know what quarter that is, Ruffians?
Do you know what the new regular quarter is?
New regular quarter?
The Mondays used to be, you know, challenge yourself.
They used to be that.
Misunderstanding.
No, it's a new regular corner, Ruffians.
Yes!
The new FUWAMOCO merch corner!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you are feeling a little tired, aren't you?
Maybe just a bit.
Tired!
Yeah.
We get it.
Just in case you wanted to know!
You know we covered last time, you know we have a 3-day showcase celebration, right?
You know, it's also a live record, so we talked about it quickly.
But, now, there is new FUWAMOCO merch!
Yeah!
Right now, Ruffians!
Let's take a look at it!
Right now!
It's hololive's 7th anniversary!
And here at FUWAMOCO, we're here all together in our special party performance to celebrate!
Yes!
Yeah!
And you can find us all together with everybody at anime store locations all across Japan!
But you know, there are actually special displays!
One-size-for-Moco panels,
So that you can find the Ikebukuro anime on the 7th floor for the 7th anniversary.
I'm sure they planned that.
I'm sure, I'm sure.
So if you have the time, please go take a photo with us, okay?
They're party girls, aren't they?
Wedding dresses.
Party, party.
It's like a wedding dress.
During the 7th Anniversary Special, you can get Merchandise Account Badges, Acrylic Stamps, Keychains, Lucky 5 Accords, and much much more!
So if you want to get your paws on them, please head over to animeokawawuffins!
Yes.
And.
But.
Uh.
It doesn't just stop there!
It doesn't stop there!
Also brand new, newly available on the official hololive shop, we have fan name keychains!
Ruffian keychains!
Yes, more!
Yeah, you can now grind yourself as a Ruffian wherever you go!
Yeah, wherever you go you're a Ruffian.
But now this keychain will remind you just in case.
Just in case you forget!
Yeah, and it reminds just like our logo!
And I think it will look great on any itabag too!
Okay, Ruffians.
There's a lot of words.
A lot of words!
We understand.
Yeah.
We're surprised too, right?
It isn't a bit much right now.
We won't let you forget, okay?
If there's really, really, really something exciting
Yeah, priority list.
The thing is, I feel like there's too much for a priority list.
There's a lot Ruffians.
Yeah, but Ruffians!
Please remember, you know, you choose what you think you're most excited for and what you want to put into your collection, okay?
No, no, no, please make sure that you do not break the bank, okay?
We really don't want you to feel stressed or anything like that, you know?
We understand that it's been a lot recently, okay?
This is supposed to be fun!
You need to eat!
It's supposed to be fun!
Okay!
Ruffians!
We understand.
We know what you're feeling.
Okay.
Food sandwich!
Eat the food, Ruffians!
Eat the food!
Yeah, okay.
We understand.
We don't want you to be stressed, that's not what we want at all, okay?
FUWAMOCO!
We both have four letters, but... Both are important.
BAU BAU!
Can you eat acrylic?
Uh, no.
There's no nutrients in acrylic, okay?
Remember that.
Food.
Acrylics.
One has nutrients, one does not now.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
Just know that we understand, okay Ruffians?
It's a crazy pace.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Bye bye!
You know, just like fan art, it's kind of another way that we can all have fun together and make something amazing!
But one thing we noticed is that for FUWAMOCO, assets are pretty rare for some reason.
But we like to use them if you like to make them fun.
Okay, Ruffians?
I'm not sure if you remember, there's a lot of Ruffians over there for our debut.
But our hashtag #helpFWMC, is actually made just for these two, you know?
You know the hashtag is for anything you think that could help us, including us.
Yeah, you know, like, oh this could be helpful, oh this could be interesting, oh whatever.
Do we have anything in mind?
I wanna see lots of Ruffians thinking we'll be fun.
What do you think would be fun?
Okay.
Sometimes there's technical limitations.
But it should be okay.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You really wanna see a swimsuit on top of a jacket?
On top of a jacket?
On top of a jacket!
Kinda doesn't really work, huh?
Yeah?
Yes!
Hi!
I don't know about the Ruffians.
Ruffians are silly, huh?
Something never change.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We are Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO!
It's Monday!
And, you know, we've been go go go going all day long.
It's been a super busy day.
We've been very good puppies.
We've been so much.
Hard at work all day.
All day long.
You know, even Mine and Channel have proud of us for being such role models.
Yes, yes.
And so you know, Ruffians, now here we are!
Here to give you a big high five and pass that hardworking baton to you so that you can do your best today, okay?
You can do your absolute best!
You can get all those things done, okay?
This is not a pup talk.
But the day's just started, you know?
Give it your all, okay?
You can do it!
All the possibilities, they're all within you!
And you know, we know it's Monday.
It's Ruffians.
But we know, Ruffians, you can do it!
You'll make us proud, okay?
Here you are!
Big high five!
BAU BAU!
Do your best, okay?
You can do it!
You motivated!
Your morning hasn't been very good?
Wow.
Here is the high five.
So that is gonna be better, okay?
It's gonna be better, okay, Ruffians?
We blew the nasty Pero clouds out of the sky.
Yeah, I'm too soft.
It's still way down on our mouth.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at some of our regular corners that aren't the merch corner.
It's not a corner, Ruffians.
It's not a corner, we're not joking.
Let's take a look at what the Doggie of the Day is today!
Today... Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
This is our Doggie of the Day!
I like this dog.
But...
He has no name!
Yeah!
Ruffians!
We give him a name!
Huh?
I just saw Maya and his doggy.
Very fluffy doggy.
Very beautiful eyes.
Yeah, those blue eyes.
Yeah!
Sort of like a certain someone, huh?
Fluffy!
Yeah!
I feel like I have some white friends.
This is a doggy I didn't know!
Marvin!
I like that.
Today's Doggie of the Day is Marvin!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
That's a Marvin.
Marvin kind of sounds like a koto, no?
A koto?
A koto, right?
Is that what a koto sounds like?
A koto is a Japanese instrument.
Marvin's kind of silly, huh?
That's a unique doggy.
Well, you know, Marvin is the Doggie of the Day that I like to just look at really nice and close to and just stick my head into all that fluff.
It sure looks like there's enough of it for both of us.
I think we can all agree this is a very good looking doggy.
Maybe even yummy too.
Maybe a bit.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Moribun!
And for today, I went on a walk.
What kind of go on a walk?
Where did we go, Ruffians?
We have de-den!
Beautiful!
It's a house hidden in plants.
I love houses like this!
You know, sometimes in the Northwest, passagees come across them, too!
Don't you always wonder what it'd be like living in there?
I wanna be behind the window and just covering all the plants!
Yeah, I feel like it'd almost be like you're being protected by them, right?
Like a big hug!
Yeah, it'd be kind of magical, wouldn't it?
Allergies?
Allergies!
If you have allergies, that's not the place to be, huh?
Is this Fauna Mart?
Wow.
We have life Fauna Mart.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing this dumb show of your life with us!
And next, we have our Question of the Day.
We have De-den!
I enjoyed the new extreme love voice part!
Thank you!
I was wondering how it was decided that you would both be on it.
I've always thought of Moco-chan as more of a tsundere character.
Maybe you need to check yourself, huh?
I don't know.
Ruffians, isn't everyone a little yandere sometimes?
Moco-chan!
Moco-chan's pretty tsund tsund, actually.
And me!
I think I'm pretty dere dere, right?
I don't know, is it that interesting that we just kind of stayed the same?
Yeah, we have to be different, right?
I was thinking that we could just become good at it.
That's kind of hard though, you know.
We just kind of get too excited when we're with you.
We get too excited, huh?
Do you want to play a game today?
This sounds more frightening like a horror game.
I'm here to protect your smile.
I thought it was Yandere!
No, it's not!
That's my best clue, dere.
Maybe it's... Maybe it's message of Yandere heart.
Maybe.
Yeah, I just wanted to give you an easier choice.
BAU BAU!
Maybe that's why.
Well, there's your answer.
Yeah.
I'm Mofin.
Better watch out, okay?
Check out my new voice pack!
And watch out because Halloween is approaching, too!
It is approaching, huh?
Yeah.
Sooner than later!
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians, thank you so much for all your submissions!
Please, you know, we love to have you part of this journey!
Moco-chan, you're breaking the camera!
It's just temporary pause.
So, please send us your Doggie of the Day!
You know, send us a little snapshot into your daily life, Ruffians!
Show us your walks!
Send us your questions!
And if you happen to see Pero, send us the misfortune of the sighting.
Okay?
Please let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Ruffians, you know, we haven't forgotten about the hashtag.
FWMCScoop2.
You know, if you have any new interesting news, hololive hololive tips, please let us know, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Mofurians!
And for our next stream, we have... De-den!
Donkey Kong 2!
Today we're gonna take a little bit of a break from... Well... I have to... Oh my god.
A lot of work.
Yeah.
According to practice.
But we might get a little bit of a rest.
Yeah.
Get our homework done so we can go to sleep early!
Yeah!
Alright!
And then we'll have even more fun playing Donkey Kong Country 2 together!
Yes!
Okay, we'll see!
Okay!
Has this nest been able to get some sleep?
No.
Why didn't it?
BAU BAU!
Let's take a peek at our schedule.
Our schedule!
Yes!
Well, this week, you know, we're up to a bunch of different things.
A lot of recreating, a lot of practice, a lot of stuff.
But on Wednesday, we'll have FUWAMOCO Morning, so we'll be able to see you bright and early once more.
And on Thursday, we're playing the brand new game from Hulu, Indie, Elite Exorcist
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I do know summer's coming to a close.
I feel like there's still a lot of summer.
I feel like there's still a lot of energy.
Let's hold out summer together, okay, love feelings?
And then, Sunday, we're gonna go to the bathhouse.
Our store bathhouse.
B-bathhouse.
B-bath.
Yeah.
Maybe some BAU BAU here and there, too.
Nice!
Oh, and Zen!
Yeah.
No go.
Nothing's gonna surprise us, no.
Announce this week's schedule!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
For Ruffians joining us through the archive today too!
Here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU!
BAUTIFUL MERCH!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Do your best to sleep well today!
You can do it!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Captain Spy!
BAU BAU!
Man Man!
Just a Flying Shark!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!